on s'est fait clasher par enora malagré
exactement c'est vrai qu'elle était hier
dans l'émission suissa dans notre ami
maxime rigaud elle a encore taclé maxine
dénicher pascal avec vous regardez alors
déjà l'été a été chez nous dans tes
papiers on va voir l'extrait dans tpm
pays et après on va voir l'extrait dans
swift je sais pas ce que vous avez avec
lcm apparemment elle n'aime pas votre
tronche et à avoir gardé déjà dans tpm
puis ce qui s'est passé ma question et
s'inscrivent dans l'équipe
selon toi après la grosse tête maxime
c'est pas méchant mais jamais un peu non
pas du tout à coup sûr le plateau pour
le voir alors ça c'était hier dans tpm
paix et hier soir elle était en
rémission swift avec maxime brillault
elle vous a remis un peu de temps j'aime
bien ce qu tout à l'heure il fait partie
de cette nouvelle génération de
chroniqueurs qui sont un peu
opportuniste et je trouve qu'ils donnent
toujours de très mauvaises infos ce
qu'il est censé avoir remplacé thierry
moreau il donne pas une bonne info mais
jamais après voilà il est brillant tout
ce que tu veux mais dans l'émission je
trouve que c'est pas exactement ce qui
lui convient ce n'est pas fait pour tp
mais je trouve pas mais c'est tout à
fait personnel non non j'ai pas de là à
la maxime à vrai dire je comprends pas
je me suis toujours bien entendu avec
est nommée rédactrice mode ça fout je me
suis toujours bien entendu avec enora
malagré c'est elle qui m'a vraiment
accueilli les bras ouverts je l'aimais
beaucoup
cette fille après mieux vaut faire
réagir que d'être totalement indifférent
là dessus et on dit souvent que l'amour
débute par la haine alors peut-être que
c'est le début d'une nouvelle histoire
d'amour avec énormément
maxime moi je trouve excellent vous
n'êtes pas prêt de partir assez gentil
c'est cool mais non plus n roll déteste
pas mais non elle est très ami avec
thierry moreau et non mais ça rien à
voir et puis moral est comme moi la
vérité d'un jour n'est pas la vérité du
lendemain on devrait donc je vous ai dit
que je l'adoré aujourd'hui plus que
jamais après année